>>In the 2006, 2007 school
year, we were listed as one
of the 30 worst performing schools
in the state of North Carolina.
>>The things that I saw when I got
here were children just running up
and down the halls,
hollering, screaming,
just a level of almost mayhem.
>>Joshua: A fair amount of them
come without any resources at all.
Some days our children go home and
they may not have a home to go to.
Some days our children go home
and there may not be food.
>>There was a lotta teacher turnover
back then and I think we were
in a mentality where it was
just about teachers surviving.
>>There used to be bullies.
Like the bullies, like make you
scared, like you didn't even want
to look at them, because they
were like, "You have a problem?"
>>Shana: Back at that
time, it kinda felt
like the students were
running the school in a sense.
>>Angela: I quit my first year here,
because it was just
so difficult for me.
>>Shana: We had a principal that
came in, maybe in September,
October of the school year.
She spent the first coupla months
just identifying everything
that we needed to change
about the school.
Number one thing is, we
had to look at our staff.
If you weren't here for the kids,
this wasn't the place for you.
>>Angela: The new principal who
came in at the time, she called me
and she said, 'Miss
Johnson, we really need you.
We know that you're
a phenomenal teacher.
Could you please just come back?'
And my only request from
her was if I come back,
something has to be different.
>>Shana: Then once we got all of the
right people, that's when we began
to look at what we were
doing in the classroom
and why our kids weren't getting it.
And we found the root
of that to be the way
that we were teaching our students.
>>Once we go over each
of these big pieces
of the lesson planning
process, you need to go back
to your plans and adjust.
Implement whatever we've learned
in the session, correct it,
revise it, do whatever that may be.
>>Four teachers from our school went
to a training in Atlanta to look
at this new instructional model,
and that's when we brought
in the non negotiables.
>>-- essential question and
then we have our key vocabulary.
Then we went to essential
and hot water thinking
questions, which we spent time on.
>>Joshua: I think the biggest
thing that we've had to focus
on here is creating a professional
development plan that's consistent.
What does research
show that really works?
And then being consistent in the
implementation across multiple years.
>>Shana: 'How do you
craft questions?'
will be one question, and then what?
[All:] How do we challenge
our students?
How do we challenge our students?
>>Angela: Now we have collaborative
learning where students are on board,
and they are participating.
And they know what to expect.
So there's a huge difference
between what it was
like four years ago and now.
>>And how like they dress
or do something in public.
So they're sagging, or
something like that?
And like the stereotypical ways, like
they come from a bad home or they're
like around bad people
or something like that.
>>Angela: Okay, so you
answered two questions in one.
You talked about the character
motivations and then you went
into one of the hot Qs, which was
generalizations and stereotypes.
>>Shana: If I were to give some
advice to any teachers, staff,
schools that are in our
situation or similar,
the one thing that I would tell
them is, you have to be intentional
about building relationships with
your students, so that they will want
to work and want to be successful.
It feels good when you can walk
around every classroom
and kids are engaged.
It's a great thing when
students talk about teachers
that they have good
relationships with.
>>Labria: I think the teachers here,
they are so hands on,
and they'll come to you.
And I think Miss Johnson cares a lot.
What is that?
That looks like a cloud.
Yeah, Do the little ruffle thingies.
Maybe you can put layers
of those- Okay, good.
>>Joshua: It's all about
relationships for us.
Having those relationships
with our staff, with each other
and with our students,
that's what works.
That's what makes a
difference here at Cochrane.
>>Angela: The reason why I do
what I do is for my students.
If I didn't get the
results that I got,
if I didn't see their
faces every day,
there would be no point
in me being here.
The gift that I receive more so
than monetary gifts is knowing
that my students are empowered.